after I've never seen a mesh before that
90 at nine a.m. okay he said about
lecture than I ok so excellent so I know
what's in your mind Alex of second I'm
sorry the significance to the italic
sub-second fine follow me second degree
yeah it's great and italic so it's not
actually so tatar it's it's it's it's a
different phone okay it's supposed to be
an earthly form ok yes significant right
it'sit's oh yeah yeah ask me ask me ask
me any questions about you Daniel you
can ask me ask me about my slides
anytime ok ok so i know to your mind
what is our we know what's all going for
to blakes it and i'll tell you i'll give
you the world's shortest introduction
one slide maintain a half and of course
what is evolution even though evolution
should have any question marks because i
believe wears a kimono has said that
among all scientific fields evolution
holds holds the record for the ratio
between people who think they know
something about when people watch I know
something about so infinite was the
comment yes so what are algorithms
algorithms you don't know is van-g novi
fee for very revolution together with
Muslim okay so this is a conveyor belt
that brings you or Muslim this is why we
have these gadgets and what they do
everything the single a fiscal system
optimized decisions process
communications you everyday you deal
with more long-bore algorithms and
people now so what is the theory of
algorithm the few other instance that
fast is good alright amino that's that's
that's actual number one
then fast means polynomial okay
polynomial time and where the first is
not always possible okay so this brings
us to complexity which is sort of the
flip side of algorithms and complexity
that's the second to evolution in this
in this in this scale that I mentioned
before all right so complexity means
sorry 04 for most of us complexity sort
of is synonymous plenty completeness and
indeed comprehend to completeness is
sort of at the core of complexity and
what do you know about if you complete
se sepa competencies terrible news okay
for the problem right let me know if I
progress the covies table because it
doesn't mean that solution will not be
found it really means that the solution
will not be clean and will not work
always and it will not will not work
exactly okay so that it's a dirty
problem and and you will not have a
clean break through like we have with
some problems right with the problems in
P then and this is important for this
talk there are more exotic shades of
complex then the completeness is good
and nice and solid and important and the
ever-present okay so we know but but
there are more exotic sketch of publix
for example factoring taking a big
number and try to find its prime factors
is not applicable it cannot be a
complete nobody expected to be able to
complete and still it's hard and I know
that you all of you believe it's hard
because all of you have used your credit
card or data okay and anybody who uses
the credit card over the internet
believes that [ __ ] is all right now
Bob and then there are some other exotic
shades of complexity which are sort of
closer to the sciences for example fixed
points is another set of complex we
don't expect which points to be ready to
complete but they're hard to find
and they they are fool you know this
insight is full of applications to the
social sciences and very important for
the stock towards then is the class pls
my friend Heidi and I gacasan I defined
it almost 14 years ago you do it now and
it's about local Optima I know that sort
of you know many people in the audience
consider sort of your getting stuck at
local Optima sort of you no sign of a
bad day ok but but the point is that but
for some of us getting sucked local
Optima is a good day or item no because
look a lot more hard to find ok so we
know there is there are problems many
problems for which you can find out it's
a you know the better algorithm for
finding local optimizer explanation ok
and we have been try very hard so we
clearly see we believe but pls is not p
ok like we believe that NPS not be we
also believe that pls finding local
optima there are hard problems with
local optima there are problems for
which we cannot find local optima right
if you won't have you want one problem
you cannot find local optimum those of
you who are interested in neuroscience i
mean a hopfield you know finding a local
optima a stable state in a hopefully
rabbit okay thats thats pls complete ok
so can you since you mention factory say
what is the scaling within that's the
less the best the best so it's something
like n being the number of the number of
the number of bits right so it's it's
it's a some sound 2 to some power of n i
eat if you wish to some power of n some
small power band smaller than not ok
right like like cubic am i right oh yeah
sorry cube root interval yeah so this is
this is the best algorithm we have right
now ok you but you can stop without
difference between worst cases and you
know so so we all understand that
complex about worst case and the light
is about typical case and of course so
every time i present complexity results
i will present with implicit humility
that this is about worse case okay so
this is this is about completes what
they intend to say about complexity and
as i said we believe that all of these
include you have to complete problems
require exponential time all right i
mean oh that's that's a that's a
contraction good i want to tell you
about one particular algorithm okay
because if you have to know one
algorithm this value should know okay
and that's that's you know that's
happened about the experts problem the
experts problem is the following imagine
that every day you must choose one of an
expert's imagine that is a financial
experts are going to give you advice
about what to buy one who sell right now
the rules of the game are the following
that the advice of an expert of expert
eye on dating you do this for a year for
few hundred days results in a game g of
I for expert eye and time and 80 which
is in the interval minus one plus one
okay so you may lose a thousand dollars
you can do it a thousand dollars okay or
anything today alright so on oh ok so
the challenge is the following you'll
notice you don't know these people okay
and then you start sort of you know or
somehow trying all the remote and so on
and you want imagine love 10 expert any
constant you want after like a few
hundred days to look back and say okay
the best x belt was expert number seven
and by god I have done almost as well as
a victim number seven okay in other
words you want to do as well as the best
expert in liquid in retrospect mind you
you do nothing about the probability
it's not a bayesian problem
you do not not know about the
distribution and in fact it's useful to
think that the experts are in fact
pranksters okay we try to embarrass you
okay who try to make you fail in your
goal okay this is sort of a useful
mindset let me know in other words worst
case is is good sometimes right and also
okay and I know you a book your thing
but you are on it can be done okay and
it's it's such an incredible factor this
can be done but he has been discovered
half a dozen times and forgotten okay so
you know in other words people forget
the shock yes so it's best is the
realization to do as well as the expert
actually has done in other words if you
have anything that if you had pick the
right expert from the beginning and
followed her advice all the way you
would be as you'll be almost as well
including right right yes yes right uh
me know so but let me know about that is
right i mean clue the everything but let
me know as i told you these experts are
really sort of you know a really this is
a really adversarial time series okay so
you know so so you ok so it has been
discovered many times like in in
economics in control theory in AI in AI
in computer science where I know what
the computer science takes hella takes
credit for discovering last not
forgetting it okay so so we call it a
multiplicative weight update okay so
what's a multiplicative weights update
all good initially you assign all X for
the same way in other words every expert
has probability 1 10 okay and then you
draw from them but you observe everybody
right I'm you know use you see how well
everybody said by Sarah whole thing of
in submission as a stock portfolio k so
I know you you you basically follow
their advice and sorry no hunt and with
one
in the beginning at each step you
increase the weight of each x 1 plus a
small concert one-percenter SI plus the
gain that result in other words if this
guy did well you booster give this guy
did but by poorly you decrease the other
weight and then of course you normalize
will keep mr. proper distribution all
right and the theorem says that it does
as well as the best expert give or take
square root of T occasion so he is how
it's done religiously up that right
right right right yeah when others are
so you are mr. Dudley that be okay how
were you dig that day and I mean I even
want to have a sort of annoying person
is the idea of the proof each day p I
becomes ti times this which is like the
items explanation of this and therefore
after many days p I is exponential of
the total performance and therefore the
portfolio will consist almost
exclusively of the boss Purcell
performing stock in hindsight okay
because this is going to be huge right I
mean oh you know it's one of these
instances where you exponentiate
something and fat suddenly clarity's is
attained unless of course there are any
other ties in which case you don't care
much and there is a possibility that you
are out of sync but this will not happen
okay so that's so this is basically why
this works or i don't know the prove
that true protease is sort of very an
insightful interment it's a it's a
potential functional okay is there a
currently n kind of correlation between
the values no these are as i told you
you can imagine usefully that the
experts are trying to to make you fail
in your goal okay if you put too much on
this talk this talk is going to go down
okay still you're going to see
and can you also do it if the game is
multiplicative so that again is knowing
where we gain ah so I'm pretty I'm
pretty sure it will you can I don't I
don't know exactly what you would do but
but I can't you know for example sort of
know them then I will guy way I guess
you would play you play this would be
logarithm sort of you know zo lauriol
yeah can you explain what happens if
each expert just completely throws it
flips a coin each day yeah okay then
there's no information of one day to the
next what I thought yes yes right
they've a minute very expensive loaf a
lot of number does it for you so that's
the easy case the conjugate oh you don't
get anything you get you you get random
you get you get nothing like you don't
practice the progression of the main the
law of large numbers does not apply it
rose a significantly about the average
and you are this you be significantly
about the average so so so Daniel the
case you man mention is this like the
van in tell you know the case that is
sort of trivial because the average of
log P is going to do doesn't let say
right you don't we don't do for the
Baron experts but the experts do
differently from each other only on a
log only and they talk that goes
linearly in log listen I am delighted
you're perplexed by this algorithm you
should be so we know we all are so you
know we you know that reflects for the
statement because you didn't define
precisely it's also saw saw saw saw that
it shows using log P no no no what the
13 sale of P what I say does it does
almost as well as absurd as the best
expert almost means give or take one
over square root of the number of days
wrong with razon whether it's on a log
scale on a linear scale it's an earlier
ski it's money okay so you know the
money you are going to get in then is 1
over square root of key 1 over the
square root of a thousand close to what
you have got them from the best actor
fusion is that expert just flips a coin
your game is always right yes exactly
it's it happen here what I presides over
the best expert could be doing more
night under me there any people who are
doing a citation algorithm this will
came on as implemented that in neural
networks and he uses exactly this it
shows yes right yeah he should I was yes
right yeah I'm not sure about the
definition of an expert say you have a
ranking of out with EJ expertise no no
you don't you don't you know nothing
about eggs no no no but I say underlying
you have a rag no generation no you just
look in bed of a thousand days you look
how they have done I understand but I am
just saying is the process of the
experts are defined you don't know it
but there's a ranking of expert but II
generation you take the best expert and
split it with the worst
I don't see I know I I don't you know
that's not what this out what it does
okay what is algorithm does sort of you
know it patiently manipulates the
weights the probabilities of the experts
okay so you know it and the end result
is that the best expert is is always
almost certain ok so now you know if
there is a winner that the winner wins
big and sorry now so it's it's it's one
of these one of these situations
probability water bikes on a seat belt
by exponentiating sort of you know you
you know you win I think you saying what
happens at the experts to take Senate
who is who is being whose best in each
year just in such complexes works no
matter of what they that's one strategy
during Apollo
so this is one strategy precisely that
will do well no matter what the heck
Spencer so I me now so you know how hard
the experts are trying to make you fail
they will not succeed so you know it is
it is inserted nose I mean oh you're
supposed to be surprised yes I mean no
you're supposed to be disbelieving I
mean oh I mean oh look at my next slide
okay so this is how you know this is how
I feel right up enough that the same
algorithms so zero sum games linear
convex programming network injection
solves an incredible array of problems
that it has no I you solved being so
you've been so so primitive and frankly
we find it hard to believe that such a
clue technique can can be so you know as
such such a Swiss Army knife okay sole
source can Santa's problems also you
know everything you want ok sorry
ammeter in the bottle which is excellent
yeah excellent yes so so epsilon is
important and epsilon epsilon has to do
with evolution good absolutely my
objection is a selection strang to you
there's no way to do much better than
the best expert in this is that it so
much better than twice a much better or
the best experts I know I'm you know I
guess this is Miss information theoretic
America I mean you know if there was
some pattern that you could pick up if
they weren't being totally adversarial
once it is yes you're lucky true but
Krista snugglebum right exactly
the evolutionary setting in the sense
that there's not a carrying capacity
where all these games across the experts
are constrained to some to some value
pretty um music it's just competitive
learning right so I'm chained oh so I'm
going I'm going to another Riyadh where
Rick spoke last time you know so I'm
going to another place heuristics
inspired by evolution okay revolution is
completely spiring okay sort of you know
so a lot of computer scientists since
the 1950s have been inspired by it and
original words for you know inspired by
it okay so and these are some some
pioneer names and basically there has
been there has been a survey called a
succession of such algorithms that that
you know mesh suemez has contributed
something said go with the winners very
simulated annealing influential proposed
by by Kilpatrick and so on tabu search
many many variants and of course genetic
algorithms okay the ladies genetic
algorithms basically as you as most of
you know they maintain a population of
solutions each is encoded sample some
kind of genotype the fitness coincides
with the goodness of the solution the
next generation is created by mutations
and visually accommodation and this was
influential proposed by Holland as a
master plan for designing effective
algorithms for solving hard problems
right now and with some theoretical
support that is going to with Google
there is in fact much more repulsion
strategies evolutionary programming
genetic programming differential
evolution and not to mention many other
sort of life inspire the like the
ever-present beehive algorithms and so
on okay and of course there is a
potential life
a sort of a very very interesting thing
going on that is sort of in some sense
very real a genetic algorithm very close
to the origin her way to the original
inspiration okay so a rascal
ossification you know maybe i'm wrong
but all these evolutions filed
algorithms i classify into a sexual
revolution sexual world simulate a
nearly that's sort of you know the the
technical term for sexual revolution is
a variance of local search one solution
or very few solutions are maintained
there isn't a shin but not a combination
whereas on this corner the regenerated
algorithms population of solutions
maintain genetic encoding new generation
produced to the megillah boy would
limitation placer copulation and this of
course corresponds to sexual revolution
which brings us to comparison and now
i'm going to make enemies in genetic
algorithms the recording is very hard to
do correctly they are so i have spoken
about genetic arguments to people to
practitioners and invariably their eyes
light up and they immediately think that
they're going to go to the lab in a week
they have shoulder problems okay you
know and and they usually don't okay
that'd be and one of the reasons is that
it takes perhaps more talent to solve to
find the encoding than to solve the
problem right let me know because the
coding is very hard to do right we must
reflect as lee has has you know i've
been making this argument for a long
time when i read it in the other blacks
work must reflect late and modularity in
the solution space and to my accounting
and I know other people with different
opinions here but let's not discuss this
now there are not many practical
successes know ok here is my here is my
my
my my definition of practice access it
is a truly important practical problem
for which dozens of approaches have
tried the seriously and I by experts and
the genetic algorithm ended up on top
okay in contrast simulated annealing I
know for a fact that people who are
doing computer-aided design of chips
consider it God's gift to to computer
aided design ok you know so that they
they really sticks out of the best-known
algo is for certain applications all
right so which of course brings us
revolution and it of course as we all
know here they was most fascinating
problem in oil I know it better than
most here because I discovered it late
in life it's it has a powerful and
comprehensive theory it has a flood of
data and still many mysteries remain
okay and just to highlight a couple
there is the mr. of the role of section
evolution there is the mystery of
variation and if you have all right so
let's talk about the raw sex sex is
ubiquitous in life despite with
multifaceted it's multifaceted costs and
there is you know there is no discussion
of the issue more competent than the 98
paper by barton chavo and this fact the
fact that sex is a bigger dose makes the
apparent advantage of simulated
annealing over j government's help
explain okay so this has been sort of
you know a and annoying you know I I
have been studying algorithms for
for the better part of the last half
century and this had always been a
stickler for me okay how come nature's
favorite trick falls on its face when
program to the computer okay and again
I'm making more more item is hereby by
the minute ok so here is a radical
thought okay that was until I met addy
and I believe during our first meeting
we came up with radicals water here is a
radical thought what if sex is a
mediocre optimizer of fitness okay what
if the performance of of genetic
algorithms was to be expected could have
been predicted okay and let me explain
this is the two locals non-additive to
do not fitness landscape painters are
the fitness of the combination in other
words Rosa relief of janae console
release of gb and the entries are the
expected number of offspring let's say
from for the genotype and it turns out
as everybody knows that in a sexual
revolution the biggest numbers will be
selected and in fact even seven will
will be wiped out and eight will will
will will eight clones will will conquer
the world if you have all the gene touch
there sorry you if you have all the gene
times if they make them yes yes i mean
if if if somehow you have you have you
have this this these 12 clones after a
while you have 2020 sorry yeah yeah yeah
yeah yes oh good
but sex favors in the transient of
course but life is in the rising alleles
that perform well in Maine genetic part
with many genetic partners in other
words the it's it's alleles that that
that that are mixable delivered okay and
so in some say you know this is sort of
the you know this this this this finding
which sort of know we we are we we estar
we support the bank mumbai much
calculation is in some sense to my mind
explains the conundrum that I had before
I me know why is it that the genetic
algorithms we know there is actually I
mean so no you want you know if if there
are there are many other ways to see
this but let me know if I delivered
disability is his his his predominant
not so there was a crucial sentence
which she get there which I think you
didn't say a month ago which was the
life is in the transient I I didn't say
the month ago but but but but you made
my life so hard because I hadn't said it
so the question is so how do you know
that life is in the trenches because
because I'm alive Daniella yeah i'm not
i'm now i'm not in my equilibrium I know
yes right
within the crucial questions of the time
scales are changing right yes yes it's
very crucial end up going to come to
that huh excellent so here is another
way to look at it here is a sort of a
peculiar genetic landscape you know
fitness landscape you have valleys as
everywhere you have Peaks as everywhere
and you have a topographical lab trade
that that is also unusual you have a
plateau ok and the theorem that we
proved with with marcos mark feldman and
addy is that unless the pigs are
ridiculously high in other words twice
the plateau where the plateau will
prevail under sense this is way try this
when you have sex every generation the
wheels are completely split up yes yes
yes or IP area yeah I don't know what
you're doing a family but yes yes ma'am
even when you can even in us that we're
talking about one gene right alright so
ending what is it is millions of
generation I understand that's right
yeah so so they do they talked about
ladybugs it but it does do same sex as
we know if you know but but I understand
I'm not fully aware yeah right the time
since a typical team has done sex is
longer than the time since each
operation together yeah sorry no no no
so so so what I'm talking about now is
eyes at the time scale that is that is
that is a finer than mutations okay so
you know in other words you you if you
keep the if you keep that the if this is
the landscape then this prediction is it
applies to sex between mutations yes
between the dead
they're on the same time what is in the
pendulum the combination mutation of
this 40 min exactly so some you know so
so so sorry no so you think you know to
variation
yes yeah it's true yes and and final
population effects and many many other
things right you all right ah ok and I
believe I believe it's time for me to
give it to give that they relate to
flash as you see mess and I are like
night and day I guess you'll get to see
ok so you know since you know yesterday
there was a there was a lot of talk
about what kind of algorithm you know
evolution must be to create all all the
life as we see around us you know what
what how powerful must defeat and so in
you know what I'll talk about is how
powerful is a Darwinian evolution as an
algorithm you know as expressed in there
in there in the laws of birth of
population genetics so we look at this
in a in a very particular regime of
weeks election so in big selection you
know if you look at the the fitness of
any genotype so that Fitness varies very
little across genotypes so so we are
going to look at this model where where
the fitness which is the expected number
of offspring is you know it says we will
think of it as varying between 1 minus s
+ 1 + s for some base model s okay and
the most important point is that the
ratio of these of these weights is is
very small is very close to one okay so
so I mean for the purpose of this
discussion i'm going to assume that that
we are looking at an organism with just
two genes but everything will apply to
two
multiple genes okay so so this might be
a fitness landscape this you know so
that that's what it looks like and now
in this regime with some you know so for
the purpose of this talk a lot also
assume that there's no linkage meaning
no jeans are independent they are not
sitting on the same clothes on but this
is this is very nice result saying that
that if you think of P IJ is as the
frequency of the genotype IJ then on the
big selection p IJ is going to be a
product distribution or very nearly a
product distribution meaning so P IJ is
the is the is the frequency with which
you see a genotype the first gene has a
lil I and the second gene as a lil J
that's that's going to be proportional
that that's going to be almost the
product of X I times XJ where X I is the
marginal distribution for for for for
illegal I and and YJ is the marginal
distribution of energy whatever the
there's no population says so this is
after this is this is after by law 1
over s generations so you could also get
it you could also get deviation from
that rising stochastically in a finite
population okay okay so so the point is
that in this particular regime you get
this yo get this very nice decomposition
where where you get almost a product
distribution and in fact what what what
this actually says is is that is that in
fact you could think of you could think
of evolution as staying very close to
what's called this right manifold where
where you're where you're exactly
product distributions so now let's let's
think of what what this is actually
telling us you know let's just interpret
this right so so you could you could
think of you could think of what we you
know what's really important here is the
genetic soup at each distribution right
that that's what we care about and the
pneus of the soup so the soup is a
distribution over the probability
distribution over over our genes which
as I said is a product distribution so
so you really think of it as as a
distribution of off of the alleles for
each gene or each locus and then and
then the distribution over over
genotypes is just a product distribution
so if you want to say what's the fitness
at this generation it's really
determined by by picking for each locus
and aleve according to the current
distribution independently and then
putting together a random genotype of
this kind and saying what's the fitness
of that one and so so in this sense you
know in this particular regime saying
that that you know what's evolution
doing well how well is it doing whether
the answer is you look at this expected
value for each generation and say how
much did it improve over the generations
that that's that yeah
why why why shunted be well yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I'm saying in this in
this particular region that's that's
that's what it looks like no no you you
might pick randomly but then but then
also you know fitness doesn't have to be
a product description the function
doesn't have to be a product function so
so even if you're picking according to a
product distribution it could be that
you know that one one is highly favored
in 0 1 1 0 and 0 0 and not favored and
then even though you pick from a product
distribution you may end up in a non
product distribution and so as long as
you have week's election you'll stay
very close to this product distribution
even though selection might lead you
lead you astray right that's that's
that's not your lackeys theorem ok ok so
so now so now we can we can turn this
around them and look at it from a
different viewpoint as a game so so what
we can say is that under evolution and
the other week selection evolution is a
game where a game is being played by the
low sigh or the jeans right it gene is
trying to trying to maximize maximize
fitness so so what's it allowed to do
it's allowed to pick a distribution on
own alleles at each in each generation
and then all the genes are in this
together right so their common utility
function is the organisms fitness and so
in this sense they are not competing
against each other there they are trying
to coordinate with each other so it's a
coordination game and then the the main
thing that that that we showed in this
particular regime is that
is that if you look at the equations of
population genetics you know you they
are equivalent to saying that the
players in this game play according to
the multiplicative weights update
algorithm right the you get exactly the
same equations in both cases okay so why
is this interesting well it's
interesting for all the reasons that
Christos herb which is that that that
multiplicative weeds is a is a very
powerful algorithm and so it's
interesting that that you know just the
just just evolution a large oven you
know already includes within it a very
powerful algorithm but but it's you know
it's a powerful algorithm when you look
at it correctly you know as in when you
formulated as the correct game with the
correct objective function okay so so
now of course when one might say look
you know this it's very nice that that
you know you know biologists might say
well it's it's very nice that the
computer scientists are finally on board
because we always thought this was a
very powerful algorithm now you know it
too right so so but there's this there's
something sorry okay so maybe
okay sorry so so let me just let me just
fell out there you know more precisely
what you know what what the algorithm is
from the point of view of multiplicative
updates so what's what's happening here
is that each locus fix its distribution
on alleles for generation t plus 1 based
on their fitness when paired with with
the distribution on alleles on other low
loss I in generation T right that's
that's what the multiplicative updates
game would do right it would sort of
each locus would look around that all
the other loss I and solo say look you
know I can I can see how how everybody
else played so far and I want to I want
to update my distribution accordingly
right ok so now now we can look at a
different way of looking at this at this
game in terms of what's called
regularization this is how learning
theories look at Blue Magic wondering
how what what was just presented can be
mapped back unto what Christmas
presented with zero it's a say now
button right what what are the experts
in this case very various the sales but
each locus has as experts are values of
the other locals they all really wish
the combination of our resources are
lost but the teams maybe this exact same
problem here is before but is it
generically let your very special cases
mostly little frequencies are going
exponentially 20 again one away all at
each site which is taking over and so
that it's very easy to follow that we'll
talk about yes
so you respected you this success or the
product of that that's what yeah it's a
big big selection yeah so let's get to
let yeah you know for now i'll talk
about this and then this is a discussion
yes okay okay so once again just to just
to make it clear they're the experts
game is being played on the alleles so
at each locus you have a probability
distribution on alleles and then and
then each locus sort of updates this
probability distribution at every
generation by saying well these ones did
well these ones did poorly the ones that
did well you increase the probability of
the ones that it worry you decrease the
probability of and that's what so so so
what this was was what the theorem is
saying is that this is how you can see
the equations of population genetics in
effect that's what they're doing right
that's another way of viewing what
what's going on now there's there's a
different view of multiplicative weights
from the point of view of learning
theory which is in terms of
regularization which is which is
basically this which is what everybody
knows off many are when you have a bunch
of data and you want to explain it you
don't really have your hypothesis go
through all the data you actually hit a
fit a nice simple hypothesis which sort
of is consistent with the data which are
without explaining anyone any one of the
points exactly and so so this is
actually what you know there's a there's
a different description of
multiplicative weights which which talks
about think think about multiplicative
rates as solving a learning problem what
is it actually doing so imagine that
each locus can base its distribution in
the generation t plus one based on all
past generations so this is now
completely unrealistic you know it's
it's looking at what happened in all
past generations and it's saying how
would I best react to this okay and the
answer is the way you would react is by
saying let me pick that distribution
that maximizes the cumulative fitness
against all passive distributions
meaning take all the fast distribution
on all other at all other low side right
and you draw from that soup the the
cumulative soup right and you you take
your your you know you take allele at
your location to maximize the fitness
the expected fitness of the genome ok so
that's one thing you could do but but
now obviously that corresponds to
fitting your hypothesis through all the
points that's a bad idea right what you
want to do is you want to regularize and
and smooth out the you know smooth out
your hypothesis so that it's not nearly
so particular and the way to do one way
to do it is look at the entropy of the
allele distribution so if you are trying
to maximize the entropy of the earlier
distribution one you know the way you
would do that is just have a uniform
distribution of all alleles but that's
also a bad idea so what you want is a
trade-off between the two right you want
to maximize some convex combination of
the cumulative distribution and the
entropy and it turns out that this is
you know this new description is exactly
equivalent to the old description of
multiplicative weights ok this is
something that was done by Manfred in
there in the 90s and then more recently
it's been greatly generalized by Iraq
Iran and Mahoney okay so so so now let's
see what we can what we can learn from
from all this so so here are a few
points so the first is that if you look
at the equations of population genetics
they are intimately tied to diversity
because because you know you have this
equivalent this description in this in
this regime of weeks election where you
can say that what what each losa is
trying to do is is maximized some linear
combination of fitness and diversity you
know entropy okay so so that that you
know that says that there might be hints
of
you know there might be insights from
this this viewpoint into this question
that crystals mentioned which was the
role of sex and you know because because
if you look at this viewpoint this
completely assumes that that you know
this is you know we were assuming sexual
recombination right from the get-go
right because because you know inherent
in this in this viewpoint that all we
get to look at at each step is the
genetic soup which is a product
distribution right so so we are already
thinking that sex sort of dissociates
different genes and and that's already
been taking into account the second
thing it does is it it it provides some
ideas about how this theory of mix
ability of Adi and christos might might
come about through the equations of
genetics because because what it's what
it's saying is you know actually your
optimum strategy might be to look at
this combination of fitness and you know
an entropy okay there the third point
that it provides is is is something
quite quite interesting which is you
know usually one thinks of diversity as
as you know as playing a playing a role
in dealing with uncertainty you know the
reason you want in diversity is because
there because the environment might
change but in fact this is telling
telling us there might be another reason
to do to have diversity which is just
four straight optimization so assume
that you have you know that that that
you know the function you are trying to
optimize against is is is fixed your
environment is completely fixed even
then just to try to optimize against it
you're doing some search in some space
and what you don't want to do is over
fit as you're going along and so so
diversity is it important then the the
next the next point is you know what's
the influence of past generations on on
this generation so this optimization
version of of multiplicative weights
tells you that in fact
what you can think of each locus is
doing as playing against a uniform
distribution over all past generations
which means that all past generations
are equally important in determining you
know in in determine the current
strategy that might be a bit bit
counterintuitive but but the way to
think about it is that your generations
might be converging and so you have many
more samples which are close to the
current generation okay so the final
point is that big selection and
multiplicative eights are both product
distributions and so you know what what
this does bring up is this question well
what you know if you want to generalize
this beyond week's election where we are
no longer in a product distribution then
we'd also have to if you want to
understand evolution in that regime then
presumably we have to generalize
multiplicative weights in some non
product form form and so that would be
actually an interesting direction to
look at if we knew you know what's the
what is an you know what's a what's a
more precise direction and way to image
to generalize week's election okay so
i'll hand over back to the lab right ah
so i'll try to finish no an hour come to
that so coming back to me know what we
talked about algorithms let's talk about
complexity for a while and I'm here to
admire very early complexity results
before any computer scientists have
probably complex the result by jbs
haldane who proved the following that
ethan adaptation happens to an
environmental change after which our era
lil favors survival then its cost
measured in measured in
in deaths of these hapless organisms
sorry no under the weight of these are
under the advance of this of this
adaptation and when units of population
is roughly the logarithm of the initial
probability of this rare alil divided by
its degree of dominant okay and the
Haldane and then later Kim Europe they
make a lot of efforts to to say how many
populations how many population sizes do
you lose a pair pair adaptation and it
turns out that the numbers between 10
and 300-400 come up okay so this means
that the regulators are paired up tation
cannot be you know is this restricts the
rate of adaptation in other words you
cannot help too many adaptations you can
have one every three hundred generation
perhaps soon after that Kimura wrote a
wonderful paper in which he says
therefore you know he makes a very
elegant argument value that information
on our genome accumulates with rate
about c per generation okay and then he
makes another very very elaborate
calculation saying that the shore we
know does the human genome which at the
time those PP your doubt can't contain
such old its information and the reason
i've been able to tell you about
numerous paper is that is the McMartin
about two weeks ago showed it was in
this in this in this program and ended
with the following very interesting
comment this is a fantastic interesting
argument except that it assumes that
selection action individual genes okay
which in some sense would have been
assuming far too long
later this morning you are going to hear
live nuts theory of mutation not as a
random event but as a genetically
informed computational event in other
words the output of a randomized
algorithm running on jeans and eat
according to live not genetic
combinations and gentle networks and the
recombination come center stage if you
make this assumption and it begs the
question what if selection acts on
genetic combinations and by the way the
matrix that that nation I have been
working on with in our presentation sort
of assumes that Jed combinations are
important because these matrices are not
out of it and of course this is this is
the most striking mr. in evolution that
the new opening talk he's opening talk
of this for a semester multi-slacking
confronted us with okay so we know that
basically the standard theory of
selection selection acting / dominant /
dominantly individual elyse elyse blood
genetic drift predict that have the rosy
casa t in a population is about the
population side very very effective
population size style times the mutation
rate definition sorry this is right
right yeah so yeah so so so Ian Matheson
it is talk described the general what is
effective population size it is a
fictional number that under some
circumstances is believed to have
something to do the population I love
the a simple way say it's a hetero
zygosity / view alright leagues besides
yes that's another salad that's already
so here Sorry Sorry Sorry heterozygosity
by the way is the chance that the you
and I are going to have a particular
locus a different different different
alley okay the different nucleotide AA
so-so heterozygosity nature seems to be
almost uncorrelated to the to the
population size um so the question is
sorry sensation the effective population
size you know survey of the second one
it makes sense sorry if you type the
subscript a on point to it make sense
PetroSA wants to be an actress seems to
be almost on correlated to the
population modulus is the actual
population with actually Sheamus if we
don't understand the internet everything
else so right sorry we don't understand
observers agosto all right we don't exam
we don't understand yeah yeah that's
what that's what I'm saying so you do
not understand is it yeah and the
question is can selection on
combinations on genetic combinations
provide some explanation so Eric sustain
this is a member of the lists of this of
this program Alberto is undergraduate
here and they have run simulations and
basically it appears but selection on
pairwise interactions of values can be
very slow to converge can be very very
very very slow to converge okay but
sometimes it seems to drive up and down
at random okay so there's not only a
random genetic drift okay there is
something else hey there is a selection
trip okay selection that goes like that
so we sex yeah sex is paramount in all
ways
Sloane is to convert seems to be to grow
nonlinear the number of low side okay in
other words if you take more and more
low side the slowest to converge gross
nonlinear handle parameters and you get
into a century like a spin glass machine
will you lock into 10 you let me let me
okay so let me let me tell you now we do
have it here that's it that's a
complexity result with causes the skull
adjacent live not both both members of
this of this this program remember this
this conjecture that I mentioned it's
basically saying that the class pls in
other words finding local Optima is ed
the hell prob okay so know that that end
there have been many pls complete
problems for which we do not have a
polynomial time all right so assuming
this assuming that a complex the world
is as computer scientists believe it
will be so now read the conclusion there
are gene networks of engines with
selection of the acting additively on a
lil pairs in other words it's not it's
not adding actually are acting
additively on alleles it adds in
actively on a lil pairs or item no so
are going just once one tiny step
towards interaction okay in which even
the weakest possible sense of
convergence always takes an exponential
in n number of the terry of generations
detroit it the fitness is a sum of terms
some of pairwise terms the sweetness is
some spare why's that exactly this is a
framework
no no no yes I understand yes I agree
what what pairs up hello did you know
pairs of jeans and all the genomes any
any correlation between just the
occurrence so so so basically you
imagine imagine you have a random
genetic network and you assign a random
a random fitness to to to the to the
frame and then and then the fitness
older you know this event venue then you
see how ok over changes some of those
right so it's like you get into the Jeep
like a spirit class which are it's very
much like a sprinkler system you exactly
yeah so how they have you know so Nix
Nix object Nick niche objections are
there is that well this assumes that you
only select on so I i believe so it's a
relative fitness in the sense that that
that that it's it's a week's election so
they know everything everything Barry it
yes I rebels every for every soma like
yes yeah sorry nonsense no how's it
different um it's it's basically if you
wish it's basically max 2sat yes
yes okay so I mean also we call
recording you've got it Michael do
according to Mike Scott you know locally
optimax Scott yes yes because that's not
that's not convenient on that one who's
on combinatorial but better that's an
interesting question so I won't talk to
you about that yeah
a fixation of Venice density instances
and Daniel are sensitive yes so and when
I say fixation I mean even get into the
right Orton will take exponential time
so pushing me this is very sensitive
just having absolutely no maintenance
innovative a mixture of additive things
randomly chosen plus pay what is the
attitude that gets don't get it so so
it's also okay so it's the additive
effects there's certainly routine where
the additive effects are typically
dominated leader fancies I'm is let's be
very strong constraint meeting the urge
to eventual solution X all right right
so yes I me know so we have done
experiments where there is a there is
additive effects plus random effects and
again you see a slowdown so you know in
fact you assume you can see a slowdown
of the sort that it fix at some point of
any three scenes like this for internet
population that's that's always a bit
more information yeah and if they need
to be also I snatched a large man I mean
that's one I tveit miss moral
exponentially larger yes yeah ah okay so
five minutes late fascinated feel deep
deep mysteries computationally side I
think simple add two to both understand
and I won't emphasize the game between
James metaphor that that who mesh talked
about and also that selection of
pairwise interaction seems to be slow
drifting and even computationally die